[Music]
welcome just swiped from a luxury spa in
the leafy sorry this week here's what
we've got for you on the program
I'll be getting an experts verdict on
the tech designed to make you feel more
beautiful Chris meets the developer dad
making games for his blind daughter and
one of the most popular intergalactic
strategy games just got remastered it's
in our review that's all to come in the
next 10 minutes or so but before then
we're gonna take a quick look at some of
the tech stories that made headlines
this week
Nokia's announced a new phone that lets
you film a both E and that's one up on a
selfie using front and back cameras at
the same time to broadcast live on
Facebook and YouTube the nokia eight is
being seen as part of hmd Global's push
to make the brand mainstream again 48%
of teenage girls say they've been
harassed or abused online a poll from
the girls rights charity plan
international UK found that among boys
the proportion was 40% nearly
three-quarters of girls said they had
taken action to avoid criticism on
social media and Amazon's delivery times
are about to get even shorter the
companies launched a new service in
selected parts of the US where prime
shoppers can collect items within two
minutes of ordering it's called instant
pickup and covers daily essentials like
snacks drinks and phone charges now this
next part of the show is all about
enhancing your face through the power of
Technology and I'm not talking about
photoshopping selfies instead I'm
referring to the increasingly tech
tastic offerings from the beauty
industry the lovely people here at Penny
Hill parks bar let me bring in a top
London dermatologist and some of the
latest Beauty gadgets for a mini testing
session
have our first beauty gadget this is the
eye derma suffix and we've got a lovely
volunteer here Katie perhaps we can pop
it on Katie
the makers call this the most advanced
anti-aging photo facial system it boasts
142 red and infrared LEDs designed to
minimize wrinkles and heal inflamed
blemishes there is actually quite a good
evidence based around LED and
near-infrared which is what this device
has because actually those sorts of
wavelengths of light can penetrate down
to the dermis and can actually stimulate
a little bit of collagen function so I
think this device is not too bad does it
feel quite hot in there Katie
little bit I feel like I'm like
sunbathing
right device number two this is the zip
it's a nano current skincare device so I
want you to go ahead and take your face
and your neck get in with the gel then
so talk to me about what a nano current
skincare device actually is so according
to the manufacturers this uses light
electrical stimulation to penetrate the
skin and then they say that it boosts
the production of something called ATP
which is an enzyme which is in all cells
your skin cells then regenerate like
boots and metabolism and you get skin
rejuvenation now the makers of the Zips
say that users could see results in just
four weeks does that sound right to you
well I'm a bit dubious about that so
every time I do any form of anti-aging
treatment with my patients I'll say that
it does take a bit longer than that
because of the way that the skin cells
cycle to actually see a biological
effect it often does take 8 to 12 weeks
the mindful touch is an invitation to
reconnect to your senses now our third
item is happening inside this tent what
is apparently 99.9% pure and I can I'll
show you the tech bit now look at this
skin bubble
another helpful volunteer Nicola is
having a facial that begins with an
eight-minute virtual reality video to
help put her in a state of mindfulness
which in turn releases oxytocin a happy
neuro chemical which then apparently
helps the skin better absorb the product
so I love mindfulness and I think it can
be really really helpful for skin
conditions which can be affected by
stress so things like psoriasis eczema
but I'm not 100% convinced that having
this during a facial is going to really
help in terms of rejuvenation Nicola are
you feeling less stressed feeling very
relaxed see until we came along and
opened up your tent sorry about that
if you have to give each of our beauty
tech offerings a mark out of 10 how
would you do that starting with the eye
derma so I quite like the idea lots of
evidence about LED technology I'd
probably give that a seven seven strong
seven and what about the zip so I think
nano current technology is coming in but
not as well established and I do find
the gel a little bit messy I probably go
for a five and the facial then
incorporated a virtual reality
experience so I love mindfulness I think
there's all sorts of great things about
it but obviously we're not quite
comparing like-for-like because these
are very much sort of rejuvenating
anti-aging episodes this is more about
mindfulness and the relaxation and by
give that six ok so the idea the idea
takes it
I want to bring you something very
different now but uplifting Chris has
been to meet a developer who's making
video games after being inspired by his
daughter but his target audience is
blind
Daisy Lloyd isn't your average teenager
she lost her sight completely at the age
of four due to the eye cancer retinal
blastoma but thanks to her dad she's
able to play video games
he makes games that use audio cues and
narration to make the experience more
accessible for blind people I used to
play games like Mario Kart on the Wii
and stuff and they say them don't have
sweet so you
we as blind people don't is actually
know what's going on it was obviously
very upsetting
when Daisy became blind for Daisy and
for the whole family but to realize that
there was more out there than what you
see as well as inspiring her dad to
create his company Daisy has also become
the chief tester for his games
with jumping saucers my dad and light
haunts like voiceover things like that
so that we know what's on the screen
it's really difficult to blindfold
yourself and test your own game so I've
tried closing my eyes and testing the
game but I haven't got a discipline
because I want to succeed of the game so
I teach this space shooter is a game
currently being worked on you tilt the
iPad to move the spaceship and sound
alerts tell you when you're in the
enemy's crosshairs so you can dodge
their attacks as you can see it's very
visual too with the aim being that it
appeals to non blind gamers as well and
this augmented reality card game is
another one being worked on by Daisy's
dad it's a kind of sci-fi Top Trumps
where you can scan the cards to get
information on them okay mr. Julian tree
for theater is as follows the feeling of
one is revealed right at the moment
games like these are the only real
option for blind people I don't think
the current set up of game game designer
triple-a or otherwise really
accommodates for blind and
vision-impaired yet but I think is
getting there
gamer accessibility is really coming a
long way in the past few years that I
can read I can read my xbox now because
there's a screen reader on it so it's
the small big things like that that are
never around before that I've really
starting to kind of build up so I think
we've got a long way to go boots on it's
starting to be on the right track it
might be a while yet before the bigger
companies start to focus on making games
more accessible but in the meantime it's
the smaller companies that are leading
the way Chris Craig and Sky News I do
feel a little bit guilty enjoying all
this blissful relaxation especially when
I think of our games reviewer Lucy the
poor things spent this week fighting a
war in space also she can tell you which
of the latest releases are good enough
to buy Starcraft is probably one of the
most important games ever made it came
out in 1998 and blizzards some 20 years
later are giving it the old remaster
treatment with darker remastered it is a
strategy game set in space very sci-fi
and it has you balanced sort of resource
management so you have to build units
send them out to collect resources use
those resources to improve your
technologies create your armies and then
you take on other races so if you're a
big fan of strategy games well you just
want to learn about strategy games and
kind of weather genre came from and
Starcraft 3 masters is definitely the
place
agents of mayhem is the latest game from
volition who are famous for making the
saints row gate let's start the show
agents of mayhem is comes weird in that
it's not a saint's row game but it's set
in the same universe and if you preorder
the game you can play as Johnny Gat
who's obviously like the main character
from Saints Row
so it's this third person game you play
as one of 12 agents so there are these
twelve playable characters and when you
go out into the game you can pick and
choose three to take with you and the
big thing about agents of mayhem is that
you need to switch on the fly sort of
adapt to the enemies that you're coming
up against all of the agents have their
own different powers abilities
personalities whole game is really
tongue-in-cheek it's kind of inspired by
Saturday morning cartoons and it's not
afraid to go near the knuckle at all a
lot of swearing that I'm kind of very
gross-out humor but if you like that
kind of thing then I definitely
recommend aged me
the original nidhogg became a must-have
for any kind of social gathering with
gamers because it is so much fun
it's so simple it's a sword dueling game
where the aim of the game is you have to
get from one side of the screen to the
other and the person you're playing
against has to do the same but obviously
the two of you come into contact and you
have to duel this time you have a
broadsword which is obviously slower but
takes a lot gives a lot more damage
there are daggers a lot faster but not
maybe as impactful and a bow and arrow
which is so much fun because you can
fire it you can fire an arrow and then
magically for some reason if you die you
appear on the other side of the screen
and you can get hit by your own arrow
it's a really fun crazy frenetic game
and if you enjoyed the original nidhogg
I'd definitely recommend a positive well
that's it for this week's show join us
again next week for more swipe and
follow us on Twitter at Sky News swipe
buh-bye
you